les mureaux un choix qui ne doit rien au
hasard si emmanuel macron a décidé de
s'y rendre vendredi c'est qu'il connaît
bien la ville
c'est en tant que ministre de l'économie
qu'il a visités en 2015 une entreprise
spécialisée dans l'impression 3d puis
candidat à l'élection présidentielle en
il s'y était rendu pour rencontrer des
jeunes talents issus des quartiers
populaires de la ville président il y a
enfin effectué un déplacement sur
l'accès à la culture en février 2018
outre les multiples visites du chef de
l'état aux mureaux la ville a aussi
accueilli en décembre 2019
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner il avait d'ailleurs
cité les mureaux comme exemple dans la
lutte contre le repli communautaire et
islamisme peut-être l'une des raisons du
chef de l'état de prononcer son discours
sur les séparatismes mur ou la création
pour les associations d'un contrat
d'engagement sur la laïcité ou encore la
pénalisation des certificat de virginité
ces mesures devraient faire partie du
futur projet de loi
elle viendrait s'ajouter à la fermeture
de lieux où l'on prêche la
radicalisation et à la création des
quartiers de reconquête républicaine des
actions mises en place au début de son
quinquennat